hey guys how are e hey guys it's Justine
I'm Jenna today we were gonna make a
birthday cake for our dog Manny this
originally was a video Jenna was gonna
make for her channel she's like you can
make it for your channel you can make it
I don't mind cuz earthy is on June 17th
which is probably today hopefully I
could sit on the day of his birth we
don't even know if that's his birthday
no we just it's the same as our dad's
birthday and when we did the math it
kind of lined up so we're like same
birthday
we talked Maddie from a shelter five
years ago I can't believe it but we're
gonna make him a dog-friendly birthday
cake so what do we need Jenna since you
picked out all these ingredients well I
ordered them online and they showed up
but we have flour apple sauce Greek
yogurt peanut butter baking soda oil oh
and the pumpkin puree which Matty hates
pumpkin puree but it's very good for
dogs in their digestion so I feel like
this is a good way of kind of tricking
him these are such cute little fans rose
I know they're really cute I have made a
mistake
you're silly 2 cup 2 cup 2 cup cups you
got a cup this is gonna be a lot of cake
this is a very organic yellow cake it's
a lot extra look don't put your that's
not yes you're not supposed to packet 2
cups hack 2 cups off that's fun I kept
soft
we've already to mask it you can work on
the wet ingredients okay 1/8 cup
vegetable oil so 1/8 and 1/8 would be
we'll just put two eights this is so
ridiculous could you imagine being math
teacher
how do you imagine being me wait do I
put this in here oh no oh I think it's
for a dog
1/2 teaspoon okay 1 I did the oil okay
1/2 cup pumpkin pie Oh No how much do we
need we need a full cup of pumpkin puree
yeah I love pumpkin I wanted a pumpkin
pie the other day but they weren't out
because it's June okay that's on three
girls all right we didn't have cup
nice okay it's not in there
I found the half cup this my grip
strength has gone in Gordon Dean
she was ended up hi Jenna I'm deleting
this video you should oh okay
I'm gonna put in to a I shouldn't be
going in order of like these things are
you reading what you're actually
supposed to be doing no I'm putting it
all in a mix together vegetable oil
peanut butter apple sauce pumpkin puree
what is there anything extra in there
what's that knots put the eggs in until
you bleed okay yeah whoo they kicked
sorry honey yes
whoa are you waiting for me I don't know
anymore this is incredible it smells
it's my favorite peanut butter look at
this
yeah it what's the word viscosity hey
hey Siri define viscosity the state of
being thick sticky and semi fluid and
consistency due to internal friction I
really want to eat applesauce and peanut
butter
you do whatever you want you're an adult
so once those are combined we combine
the dry ingredients with them and have
to do it gradually I say okay yes hold
on a second let me give this casa D
you've got whirl put that think you flew
in a Vista I don't lip stick that in
there since I've been live streaming it
isn't bringing out my absolute just
insanity bringing it out
well yeah but like I can subside it when
I'm making YouTube videos but now that
I've been live streaming like I'm
you're just fine this is what you are I
know this is what people signed up for
13 14 years ago yeah alright this looks
pretty viscous the viscosity looks
pretty good now mix I'm trying to find a
pour mixture into an eight inch round
pan don't even think you're doing this
didn't even want to cuz every time you
don't do a good job being dramatic
I'll brush my hair I just don't feel
pretty why the hair so let's put it
wow that's grease free stuff looks like
kind of looks like his belly issue yeah
this is not that he's bad this isn't
like an excited tape
you won't like lick the batter have you
tried it I'll try it what's in here
pumpkin egg fine it's all edible it's
all like human there's no sugar so it's
probably like other than the applesauce
very bitter okay it's not like that at
all listen well it's like very close
like you try it no I'm good no I want to
have to try the luring noise
what you making me do things I don't
want to do really didn't like it how
long what does it say let's make
approximately for 25 to 30 minutes or
until a toothpick inserted into the
center comes out it's presumably the
same it was a cake hey Siri set a timer
for 25 minutes we have to put these in
there or until a toothpick no I cannot
get that taste of this out of my way to
make the icing oh well I'll clean this
and then this just might be icy like
baby vomit now we're gonna make the
icing well this is her doubling the
recipe so it says 1/2 cup plain Greek
yogurt but we're gonna
double it did you guys know that we were
doubling the recipe we're gonna double
the recipe so there's a hat cup no
that's a whole cup well we get that's a
whole Cup we need a whole cup we do we
were doubling the recipe Maddy better
appreciate us he sewed it all you just
want a little dog cereal every I'll put
that peanut butter a lot of peanut
butter it is a long peanut butter but we
can't let him actually get the whole
thing he'd have a little thing like one
tiny little bite how's it going do you
want a different mixing utensils like us
no maybe looks fine oh oh they look
really cute no should be should you take
those other ones out the little guys
like to I put this in the fridge now I
should private in the fridge right I
can't use my foot that would be hot
should I put in the fridge oh this isn't
very no oh this is where I am now here a
toothpick crunchy it's not crunchy
Oh oh god that's disgusting
I don't like it at all not a single bit
done what it's way better than the cake
hmm no that's not ready it's not ready
when you see us again
we'll be icing the cake actually this is
a good segue out so gonna me up
like you know get out of here
the cakes are out at the other guy shut
the oven off give thumbs up I play okay
I'm gonna off the way out we took the
cakes out of the oven and now we're
gonna ice them up we just took Maddie
for a walk and told her there was gonna
be treats at home he's staring at it
come here buddy come here
Uvas you go you're behind your face let
me get that you want to keep the stick
there I was gonna flip it what this way
yeah
do you want to do a little no no it's
what's for the good well to make it like
a flat well while you do that I'll work
on his side treats okay oh that's really
cute Maddie this is gonna be so exciting
yeah your organs will let you chow down
I'm oh my god I miss icing cake icing
cakes to me is so therapeutic I
absolutely love it it's my least
favorite I used to spend so much time on
a red icing cakes to make them perfect
you want to smell it see if you're
interested come here they're like it's
your birthday cake you think he knows
that through him I don't know if you
know this for him
this is for you bud is that look good
but good for you but that's for you oh
yeah he's gonna definitely have a
squirts tonight just give me a cup on it
so I'm gonna just ice this up do what I
want what I want with my body if regular
candles man you want one candle for your
birthday
you can't even blow it out cuz you're a
dog all right Jess I think you did a
good job you got I'm not done yet
okay you're doing a good enough job stop
but it's not done yet it's not perfect
it's perfectly done here Oh it'll come
around to you oh my god you're six years
old we're not gonna light it for you
we gonna candle out okay look Oh
okay she's cutting it for layered I mean
let me just talk about my icing skills
wait you're we're it's good good boy
good boy
it's your treat you'd be a brave good
job all right I'm gonna try it I'm not
it looks good but that's not good you
like this
happy birthday Maddie you're five years
old okay you're terrified of plates oh
he is afraid of plates it doesn't make
sense
oh boy sweetheart come here everybody go
watch Maddie a happy birthday on
Instagram his into his DJ minimaps and
he's an angel and he has five he's five
he's perfect also everybody um what
follow us on Twitter we also have a
discord server I'll put all the links in
description okay happy birthday bud we
love you there you go go be free go be
free go be free took four hours
[Music]